bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur l'efficacité de
la lutte contre le dopage est
actuellement aux états unis pour
poursuivre ses investigations
elle se rendra également la semaine
prochaine en suisse pour rencontrer
michel platini à l'uefa
elle se rendra également au siège du cio
le comité international olympique
en attendant la semaine dernière la
commission a poursuivi ses auditions
avec notamment des membres de la
fédération française d'athlétisme
audition que je vous propose de suivre
tout de suite
chers collègues nous abordons une
nouvelle étape de la réunion d'autres
commission d' enquête sur le dopage vous
accueillir et saluer de votre part c'est
bernard amsalem président de la
fédération française d'athlétisme et
dany halouze directeur technique
national
messieurs bienvenue
je m'adresse d'abord en quelques
personnes qui sont dans les tribunes du
public pour leur indiquer que le
principe
lorsqu'il ya commission denquête c'est
la possibilité pour ces personnes de
manifester positivement ou négativement
leur opinion sur ce qu'ils peuvent
entendre le silence est de mise
merci de bien vouloir le respecter quant
à vous monsieur le président ce
directeur technique national
je suis obligé de soumettre une petite
formalité commission denquête nécessite
prestation de serment
j'ai donc vous demander à l'un à l'autre
de bien vouloir dire la vérité toute la
vérité devait la main droite est dire
juge sir le salam je jure de dire que la
vérité rien que la vérité
merci je jure de déshérités nous allons
entrer si j'ose dire dans le vif du
sujet le principe c'est de vous donner
la possibilité en répartissant le temps
où un seul prend la parole vous arrangé
entre vous de parler pendant dix minutes
un quart d'heure sur le sujet qui nous
occupe
et puis nous aurons la possibilité avec
jean jacques lozach trois rapporteurs
qui est à l'origine cette commission
denquête madame michèle qui nous a
rejoint qui s'est mise un peu dans le
fond de la seule mais elle était reçue
pickas et vous le verrez bien nous avons
la possibilité après cet exposé
liminaire que vous allez faire de vous
interroger sur deux trois sujets qui
nous préoccupent
je vous donne la parole d'abord vous
nous avez demandé ni ces documents que
nous avons pas mener aujourd'hui mais
que nous allons vous transmettre le
demandiez des statistiques relatives au
nom de 2
de sanctions dans ce domaine là est bon
il fallait remonter jusqu'en 2006 donc
ça nécessitait un peu de temps de
recherche vous aurez tous ces documents
dans les prochains jours évidemment tout
ce que vous avez demandé vous sera livré
juste un mot alors sur plutôt la saison
l'année 2012 c'est la dernière année
pour vous dire que la fédération a
exercé en direct un peu plus de 1000
contrôles 1021 exactement et que sur ces
1000 contrôles au travers donc de des
championnats des compétitions diverses
et variées et même certains contrôles
hors compétition
nous avons eu 17 licenciés 17 athlètes
licenciés qui ont relevé donc d'une
procédure
de sanctions disciplinaires à noter que
sur ces 17
il y a quatre athlètes de haut niveau
inscrits sur les listes de haut niveau
et que sur ces deux athlètes de haut
niveau en réalité il y en a deux pour
lesquels il y avait donc il n'y a pas eu
de suites de donner c'était des des
problèmes d'un but et surtout ces deux
athlètes été blessé et donc on
traitement donc voila c'était lié par
contre il ya eu deux athlètes suspendus
pour donc fait de contre contrevenant
aux règles du dopage et en particulier
nous avons nous avons la commission
discipline a émis la sanction la plus
lourde de l'histoire de l'athlétisme
puisque sur un des deux athlètes
récidiviste il a été suspendu dix ans
autrement dit sa carrière est terminée
quoi on athlétisme en tout cas voilà je
crois que c'est la plus forte sanction
émise en france par une fédération par
une commission disciplinaire fédéral ça
c'était pour juste alors dans l'es17 ya
aussi beaucoup d'athlètes anonyme
enfin anonyme 10 ans hier la fédération
mais qui sont pas des athlètes de
premier plan et qui sont souvent des
athlètes qui pratiquent l'athlétisme je
dirais presque en terme de loisirs et
qui passe souvent par inadvertance ont
absorbé un produit interdit sans le
savoir
voilà mais les sanctions évidemment son
lait sont les mêmes au total il ya 4,4
sanctions liées à de l'eau p o à la
prise de le pays sur les 17 mai jeu vous
donnera à ces chiffres
ces statistiques vous les aurez avec
l'ensemble des statistiques nous avait
demandé je voulais faire plusieurs
observations sur la liste sur la lutte
contre le dopage
je préconise depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années une évolution des
règles de lutte contre le dopage
l'athlétisme comme d'autres sports est
soumis au dopage
contrairement à beaucoup de fédérations
nous nous avons pris le taureau par les
cornes c'est à dire nous avons considéré
que le dopage est de ne ne devait pas
être un sujet tabou dans notre milieu et
en 2006 nous avons commencé à prendre
conscience véritablement du problème et
à partir de 2006 2007 nous avons à la
fois une attitude extrêmement comment
dire attentive à ces problèmes moi même
je me suis un petit peu fort mais
puisque ça ne découvraient ce ce sujet
par des rapprochements avec les services
de police spécialisés en particulier
avec la fld j'ai pu j'ai pu prendre
connaissance un peu des dés à la fois de
type de produit prix de méthodes
utilisées et c'est ce qui m'a permis
finalement aujourd'hui de bien de bien
connaître un peu à la fois les circuits
généralement des petits circuits c'est
pas les grands circuits de la drogue
mais évidemment mais aussi les méthodes
utilisées
un pur pour effectivement subir des
traitements biologiques entre guillemets
évidemment qu'ils préparent à la
performance
à titre personnel j'ai aussi observer
les athlètes de l'équipe de france les
athlètes les meilleurs athlètes dans
leur révolution de performance
moi je suis à titre personnel passionné
par la la statistique en matière de
performance et surtout la progression
et quand on quand on note des
progressions erratiques ou extrêmement
forte d'une année sur l'autre
on peut penser qu'il peut y avoir des
problèmes surtout quand ça arrive en fin
de carrière
quand ça arrive à 20 ans ça peut être
encore possible mais au delà c'est c'est
suspicieux et donc on a mené la lutte
contre le dopage on a suspendu en 2006
une douzaine d'athlètes de l'équipe de
france donc en étant extrêmement plus
prégnant sur sur leur leur suivi sur le
également de la connaissance de leur
présence dans les stages les stages
alors il ya des stages nationaux cela il
n'y a pas de souci ils sont en garde est
encadrée par la fédération
parfois il peut y avoir des stages
individuels ou de groupe que nous ne
maîtrisons pas mais nous avons essayé
d'en avoir la connaissance
nous avons aussi mis en place depuis
maintenant six ans des campagnes de
prévention donc qui sous la forme sous
plusieurs formes d'abord des documents
donc affiche
deux documents de papier distribués dans
les clubs et en même temps
l'organisation de colloques de
conférences à travers la france on en
fait à peu près 20 par an depuis six ans
dans toutes les régions de france et
nous nous associons assez assez assez
interventions des athlètes de haut
niveau
parfois même des athlètes de haut niveau
qui ont été suspendus espèce de repentis
en quelque sorte et qui parle de vent
donc soit des entraîneurs soient des
dirigeants de clubs soient des athlètes
aussi de deux pôles de bas de ce qui
s'est passé pour eux et ce qui les a
conduit à abandonner à dériver donc ces
opérations de prévention nous les nous
les menons parfois avec des
représentants de la fld qui nous
accompagnent et donc nous faisons
quantité face chaque année à peu près à
un horizon de 20 interventions sur le
territoire
et puis voilà donc un peu l'action de la
fédération mais je ceci dit nous nous
posons un ensemble de questions sur la
réglementation j'ai un exemple tout
récent je vais commencer par celui ci
nous avons un athlète qui a réussi la
semaine dernière une performance
exceptionnelle au marathon il a gagné le
marathon de séoul avec un temps qui le
situe dans les meilleurs du monde et qui
devrait normalement le qualifier pour
les championnats du monde de moscou
or cet athlète est éteint et suspendu
suspendu non pas pour raison de dopage
mais dans le cadre du suivi médical des
athlètes qui débat qui est notre
responsabilité aussi le médecin donc qui
a observé des irrégularités sur les
paramètres qui la contrôlait m'a demandé
sans me dire ce qui se passe exactement
après tout ça peut être
selon le code du sport ça peut être un
problème médical tout bête une maladie
en l'occurrence on a des suspicions la
de dopage véritable et m'a demandé de
suspendre ce que j'ai fait et sur le
territoire national cette suspension
évidemment sa force de loi mais dès
qu'on sort du territoire national il ya
plus de possibilités de contrôle et donc
personne ne savait la fédération qu'il
allait faire le marathon de séoul
voilà voilà donc ça c'est c'est un
problème que nous avons et si jamais il
y avait à réfléchir sur une évolution de
la réglementation devrait trouver une
solution alors
sur ce sujet médical je note que il ya
peu de pays qui sont une réglementation
spécifique là dessus la france étant un
des rares pays à le faire
ce suivi donc consiste à contrôler les
paramètres trois fois par an avec un
médecin qui est à l'extérieur donc de la
fédération et et c'est pour nous pour
les coureurs de fond ou de demi fond
nous les contrôlons entre quatre et six
fois dire qu'on a renforcé ce sujet
parce que on sait très bien que c'est
dans ces disciplines là qui a le plus
fort risque de dopage notamment à le
pays dopée aux hormones de croissance et
autres
donc voilà voilà un exemple concret
d'une situation où on est on peut pas
agir et donc voilà en plus cet athlète
est d'origine kényane il est devenu
français par un engagement dans la
légion étrangère
donc on n'a pas vu arriver si vous
voulez au bout de trois ans pendant
trois ans on les connaît pas et bio ou
trois ans ils deviennent français est
donc aujourd'hui il est sorti du cadre
de la légion étrangère
en fait il vit au cannet au kenya il
s'entraîne au kenya on n'a aucun moyen
de contrôle même s'il est licencié à la
fédération et dans un club français qui
lui-même donc un moyen de contrôle voilà
donc la voilà une situation qui se pose
pour nous et qui nous interroge parce
qu'on n'a pas les moyens de d'agir sur
cette situation
dans notre exemple d'athlètes des
exemples qui nous pose problème hein on
a suspendu l'athlète juste avant les
jeux pas pendant les jeux qui était
sélectionné aux jeux d'ailleurs et
il a été contrôlé deux fois après des
difficultés pour le trouver dans le
terme dans le domaine de la localisation
il ne répondait pas ni aux courriers ni
aux messages mails ni au téléphone fin
bref il a fallu même faire intervenir
les services spécialisés de police pour
trouver où il était donc on a réussi à
le trouver et quelques jours avant son
départ
à londres il a été contrôlé à deux
reprises et les deux contrôles étaient
positifs à l epo donc quand on a eu les
résultats après sa course
la bande à châtenay malabry été fermé il
a fallu envoyer le contrôle à lausanne
donc ça a bien peu plus de temps jeu les
convoqués en tant que chef de mission
olympique à londres et je lui ai notifié
donc son renvoi du village olympique
mais après sa course donc il a pu faire
sa course et ce qui est dommage et est
donc ça s'est passé au mois d'août la
licence chez nous est valable du 1er
septembre au 31 août
nous ne pouvons intervenir que sur des
athlètes licenciés adhérents à la
fédération
il n'a pas repris sa licence tout de
suite donc vous savez dans la procédure
il ya l'examen du flacon à celui ci
était positif et pour faire le flacon b
il faut lui lui signifier donc et le
convoquer il a été convoqué il n'a pas
répondu comme d'habitude il a joué la
montre et donc on est arrivé au 31 août
et la plus de licence donc plus de
possibilités pour la fédération de
continuer la procédure
donc nous avons transmis le dossier à la
fld qui elle la fld a pu poursuivre
cette procédure mais il a fallu attendre
le 25 mars donc c'est tout récemment la
fld enclenché donc la procédure
disciplinaire
elle même ayant eu du mal à le
le convoquer elle retrouvée à le faire
venir et donc il a été sanctionné par la
fld seulement le 25 mars une affaire qui
s'est déroulée début août de l'année
dernière
donc voilà ça c'est aussi pour moi un
problème quand un athlète est licencié
dans la fédération et qu' il ne reprend
pas de licence à la rentrée eh ben ils
échappent au contrôle de la fédération
ça se voit là c'est une question qu'il
faudrait sans doute aussi examinées
voilà pour les des exemples concrets
pour illustrer en quelque sorte les
difficultés qu'on peut qu'on peut vraie
vie vivre récemment il ya des questions
par contre lyon d'un général que je me
pose et
la première question c'est sur le suivi
médical
j'en ai parlé on nous dit dans le code
du sport c'est un c'est une règle de
suivi donc médical sur la santé des
athlètes
or nous on n'utilise pas comme ça on
utilise comme comme une action de
prévention ou de recherche de gens qui
se dopent pourquoi on ne dit pas que
c'est une action pour traquer les
tricheurs
c'est comme ça qu'il est utilisé en tout
cas chez nous alors évidemment temps en
temps le médecin qui exerce ce travail
voit bien qui peut y avoir des
pathologies particulières mais à la
limite j'ai à dire c'est même c'est
secondaire pour lui puisqu'il est là
pour regarder si les paramètres sont
paramètres sont bon s'il n'y a pas de
prise
extérieur de produits dopants donc là il
ya je trouve qu'il ya une certaine
hypocrisie dans ce système et moi je
considère qu'il faudrait clarifier les
choses sur ce plan la deuxième
deuxième observation
le secret médical le médecin est soumis
au secret médical
ça me gêne pas pour tous les patients
dont il a la charge
mais pour les sportifs de haut niveau ça
me gêne ça me gêne parce que dans
certaines situations le secret médical
c'est une façon de protéger l'athlète
c'est de savoir qui se dopent ne pas le
dire je trouve que c'est contraire à
l'esprit de la loi sur la lutte contre
le dopage et donc je prends je préconise
que le secret médical pour les sportifs
de haut niveau soit levée alors
évidemment on va se heurter aux
problèmes de l'ordre des médecins qui va
s'offusquer etc mais dans certaines
situations
je pense que ça peut être extrêmement
dangereux et on peut aussi penser qu' il
ya des médecins qui protège les athlètes
de ce point de vue là alors je le dis
pas pour l'athlétisme mais sans doute
dans certains sports professionnels
surtout quand ils sont salariés d'un
club peut on peut penser tout ce qu'on
veut voilà donc je n'en dirai pas plus
sûr c'est évidemment sur sûr cela ça me
concerne pas directement mais c'est une
observation que je voulais faire voilà
les observations je voulais faire sur le
plan médical sur le plan donc des
sanctions de la juridiction enfin des
bons j'ai vu que la loi et fait évoluer
un peu les choses j'avais préconisé
depuis longtemps que la sanction la
première sanction évidemment soit
fédéral commission disciplinaire fédéral
que la deuxième soit externalisés ce qui
a été décidé récemment et c'est je crois
que c'est une très bonne chose mais je
pense qu'il faut aller au encore plus
loin et en particulier parce qu on a eu
quelques soucis nous depuis quelques
années sans doute aller vers la création
de juridictions spécialisées dans ce
domaine du dopage sportif on a affaire
parfois alors vous savez quand quelqu'un
est suspendu
quand il est contrôlé positif en général
il ya des avocats qui se présente sans
que l'athlète à aller chercher
voilà qui se pointe église moi je vais
vous défendre on trouve sur la forme
souvent des failles souvent parce que
à l'époque la réglementation française
n'était pas tout à fait en accord avec
la réglementation de l'ama d'ailleurs à
chaque fois que la main change ses
règles nous la france videmment on
s'adapte mais ils on met un certain
temps avant de s'adapter
donc ça il peut y avoir une année entre
le décalage entre ce que la main a
décidé est ce que nous nous allons donc
mettre en oeuvre sur le plan
réglementaire et bien pendant cette
année là y'a des vides juridiques et
donc là la justice classique souvent et
mal informés de cela ne connais pas
spécialisée dans les domaines de
présence de ce2 de dopage et nous avons
des nous avons eu des dossiers où on a
été houleux la claque a été donc
réhabiliter donc alors que le programme
que le dopage était réel il avait été
suspendu pour des problèmes de forme de
simples formes
alors parfois des problèmes de forme qui
dépendent à la fois du problème du vide
juridique mais aussi parfois des
problèmes de forme qui est lié à la
manipulation de la procédure
un au laboratoire quand on contrôle etc
il peut y avoir
voilà c'est arrivé plusieurs fois et on
a laissé échapper comme ça des athlètes
qui se dopaient réellement dans les
faits étaient réels mais qui finalement
pu continuer à exercer leur leur leur
art sans problème et donc moi je
préconise que finalement on aille vers
des juridictions spécialisées après tout
il ya bien des tribunaux pour le travail
droit du travail
pourquoi il y aurait pas les tribunaux
spécialisés pour le droit du sport
alors ça irait au delà de questions de
dopage évidemment ça suffirait pas pour
alimenter le travail mais il faudrait
enfin je sais pas je pense qu'il ya un
jour où l'autre la y arriver c'est
autant que dans le sport y a pas que le
problème du dopage et d'autres problèmes
avec les paris avec cette chose qui
aujourd'hui commence à prendre de
l'importance
donc externaliser les sanctions la
fédération le rôle d'une fédération ne
peut pas être un rôle de juge et partie
me semble-t-il la fédération son rôle
principal majeur c'est de prévenir c'est
de mettre en place des actions de
prévention
de veiller à tout cela mais après de
sanctionner je pense qu'il faut vraiment
aller plus loin et donc de confier le
côté sanctions à des spécialistes à des
spécialistes extérieurs à la fédération
on considère qu'on n'a pas ce rôle là
bas on applique la loi telle qu'elle est
mais voilà je suggérais ce genre de
choses voilà les observations je voulais
faire voilà boudé observons que voulait
faire et je suis évidemment prêt à
répondre à vos questions
merci ce président moi j'ai juste deux
trois petits points président
allons-y donc je rejoins parfaitement
puisque on travaille vraiment en étroite
collaboration on est vraiment là depuis
j'arrivais à l'athlétisme
je sais que mon président ccc une
bagarre s'est on n'y tient pas ce qu'on
veut on va avoir un sport propre
et je tenais juste à rappeler sur le
fait du cas qu'il a il a exposé du
marathonien
effectivement nous la dtn en phase avec
le président puisque on travaille
ensemble on a mis un comité de sélection
et il faut savoir que il est
sélectionnable
il n'est pas sélectionné même en ayant
fait les minima sélectionnable parce que
c'est bien rappeler et c'est très précis
dans les modalités de sélection
c'est à dire s'il n'est pas à jour sur
son suivi quels qu'ils soient
il n'est pas sélectionné même en ayant
fait les minima
donc je pense que c'est quand même un
acte fort c'est qu'ils démontrent que
vraiment qu'on est con et vigilant là
dessus et
et ce terme sélectionnable est très
important même si ça peut paraître mais
c'est un mot qui fait quand même un
petit peu on va dire reculer certains
c'est certes un tricheur
moi j'ai juste une quelque chose qui me
tient à coeur c'est c'est concernant
leno show
il ya deux poids deux mesures j'ai
certains athlètes quand c'est
l'athlétisme
ça peut aller de 1 à 4 à 2 en concerner
d'autres ça peut aller de trois mois à
six mois mois il faudra juste
m'expliquer donc heureusement qu'on a de
très bonnes relations avec la fld
vraiment qu'ils nous aident énormément
et qui les athlètes explique un peu
parce que c'est quand même lourd de
conséquences
j'ai pas connu ça mais quand je vois
j'ai une population quand même très
hétérogène
gdg dg des athlètes qui savent très bien
écrire qu'ils savent quand des agents
qui sont bien accompagné qu'on jamais de
souci j'en ai d'autres qui sont plutôt
isolé mais qui sont performants et
qu'ils ont des fois du mal et qui font
des erreurs de deux jeunesses
on a tous fait des erreurs de jeunesse
je pense qu'à un moment aussi là dessus
il faudra aussi se pencher sur ce cas là
parce que pour quelqu'un qui a et je
veux dire c'est c'est un petit peu lourd
quoi c'est jerry triche pas ils ont pas
été là donc après il faut revenir et moi
je remercie la fld parce que vraiment
ils sont allés coûte de 2,2 de l'athlète
et de la fédération ils nous font
confiance
on peut pas reproduire deux fois la même
erreur mais bon au bout de trois
no-shows ça veut dire que t'étais pas là
mais tu prends comme deux ans de
suspension
bon ça c'est un petit peu je trouve que
c'est un petit peu dur
voilà on fait pareil pour tout le monde
mais pakala thétys
voilà c'est tout
merci si le président m'autorise je
voudrais poursuivre ce que disait ghani
yalouz pourquoi y at il des différences
de traitement avec des durées de peines
différentes selon qu'elles fédération
selon quels problèmes de vous dire
pourquoi je crois que bernard connaît
peut-être mieux le dossier
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
président vous connaissez mon parcours
je suis toujours attaché à d'autres
sports donc je vois ce qu'ils achètent
je suis pas dans la délation c'est pas
moi c'est pas ma philosophie c'est pas
voilà tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que vous constaterez ou frais
l'état des lieux vous verrez que sur des
lots chaud il y en a qui ont moins mais
par canton attelé on prend beaucoup ça
c'est sûr c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
le président permettez que vous ayez là
dessus des statistiques de la fld qui a
tous les éléments pour à titre
comparatif de regarder comment ce
problème de nos shows est traité d'une
fédération à l'autre et effectivement
gagné a raison dans certains sports
professionnels de jeu de l'équipe
on voit bien que parfois le no show est
sanctionnée par un arrêt de travail
parce que là en l'occurrence on est dans
un sport professionnel de un mois deux
mois trois mois
rarement plus un c'est vraiment plus
alors que effectivement dans d'autres
sports
non qualifiée de professionnelle comme
comme un autre eh bien nous on est entre
un an et deux ans selon la qualité de
ces nos shows soit si les nos shows
volontaires soient cédés au chaud à
volontaires donc voila et donc on a une
marge entre un an et deux ans nous on
est on est prêt à admettre ça un an ou
deux ans mais il faudrait que ce soit la
même chose pour tous les sports jeux
réitère ma question pourquoi cette
différence de traitement
s'il faut il faudrait poser à aux
fédérations concernées
je sais pas nous en tout cas nous on
respecte la règle et en donnent entre un
an et deux ans selon les situations mais
n'a jamais on n'avait jamais été en
dessous d'un an
est ce que il faut maintenir le principe
que ce sont les fédérations qui prennent
les sanctions
peut-on rétablir l'équilibré confiant
par exemple à la fld le soin de
prononcer la sanction qui serait plus
uniforme
nous aurions intérêt à ce que ce soit
externalisée je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure en toute sanction quelques quel
que soit quelle qu'elle soit soit prise
par un organe extérieur aux fédérations
lors de nos questions restaient d'en
finir et à définir
ça peut être la fête des fous alors à
côté des soldats une structure juridique
spécifique raimbourg ça c'est en tout
cas la fld nous nous a toujours soutenus
parce qu'on a il fallait qu on argumente
et nous a soutenus dernièrement pour un
dernier cas et de quelqu'un d'un fort
potentiel
on va dire olympique et ça aurait été
dommage et on a dû argumenter faire des
attestations et la fédé il l'a fait la
fld nous a vraiment accompagner
conseiller est à notre écoute
justement après savoir qui pour quoi
voilà uniformiser je pense que c'est le
bon terme pour moi très bien merci
jean jacques lozach oui monsieur le
président et le directeur vous avez bien
compris que la raison d'être de notre
commission c'est accroître l'efficacité
de la lutte contre le dopage partir du
moment où on est dans un système de
tolérance de tolérance zéro en la
matière donc une première question mais
à caractère très très générale de porter
très généraliste sur l'organisation sous
la gouvernance de cette lutte antidopage
dans notre pays le rôle de l'état le
rôle du mouvement sportif
la fld laboratoire de châtenay malabry
et c'est à la lumière de vos expériences
quel regard vous j'étais là tu es dans
quelle direction il faudrait s'orienter
si des modifications doivent être portés
bien alors aujourd'hui le système est un
système où il y à de multiples
intervenants et encore une fois je le
répète les fédérations leur rôle c'est
évidemment d'être concerné par les
problèmes de d'éthique de dopage mais le
rôle juridique des fans de sanctions est
un rôle qui me semble-t-il pourrait peut
être porté par un organe extérieur je le
répète notre rôle à nous est un rôle de
prévention nous avons avant tout les
fédérations rôle de formation
d'éducation à la compétition
performances et donc avec tout ce qui
évidemment permet la performance est à
dire l'hygiène de vie
le l'éthique etc ça c'est notre rôle est
on est on est fondé de continuer à
travailler là dessus
par contre dès qu'on arrive à des as des
as des tricheries
je crois qu'il faut il faut sortir de la
fédération et il faut effectivement
qu'il y ait une autorité alors je sais
pas si c'est la fld le laboratoire
peut-être que cd c'est une structure qui
rassemblerait tous là y compris
d'ailleurs des représentants du
mouvement sportif et est donc une
structure extérieure qui serait appelée
à avec des techniciens des spécialistes
à la fois médicaux à la fois juridiques
qui seraient amenés à prendre les
sanctions vraiment l' avantage que j'y
verrai c'est ces deux d'uniformiser les
sanctions tous sports confondus
parce que on a la pression et nous on le
dit parce qu'on fait partie avec le
cyclisme des sports les plus contrôlés
que ce soit nous mêmes en tant que
fédération ou les interventions
extérieures des fédérations
internationales ou des who de la fld
nous sommes des sports les plus
médiatisés sur ce plan là et nous avons
le sentiment que c'est parfois très
injuste notamment depuis quelques années
ou à la fois la fédération cycliste et
nous-mêmes vous ont fait des efforts
conséquents pour prendre à bras le corps
cette ce problème de dopage
et voilà donc moi je me réjouis que
récemment on ait eu on est vu une étude
du laboratoire je crois sur les
statistiques en matière de dopage sport
par sport et que finalement il le
cyclisme l'athlétisme n'arrive en tête
même si on fait encore partie des sports
ont conservé bien entendu on en n'a pas
la prétention de dire que tout est clean
chez nous donc voilà donc nous avons en
plus d'une fédération internationale qui
est très à cheval sur ces questions là
la fédération l'ietf qui aujourd'hui a
mis en place un système de passeport
sanguin l'échelon international et qui
donne des résultats qui commence à
donner des résultats extrêmement
important puisque récemment une
quinzaine d'athlètes ont été suspendus
sur la base de ce passeport sur des des
exams ac
ddd d'examen qui ont eu lieu il ya des
bouts en 2000 en 2011 et même au delà à
berlin en 2009 et on a conservé dans des
échantillons et des athlètes russes qui
ont été suspendus et sk kenya ce qui a
permis d'ailleurs à des athlètes
français de récupérer des médailles
alors toujours c'est pas terrible de
récupérer une médaille plusieurs années
après mais bon dans le palmarès ça
restera donc nous avons vraiment une
fédération qui fait un travail énorme là
dessus
et qui donne des résultats donc il ya
vraiment une prise de conscience un plan
international de notre fédération nous
nous emboîtons donc le pas de la
fédération c'est pas le cas peut-être de
tous les pays du monde et en particulier
il ya des encore des continents entiers
qui qui qui sont pas soucieux de ces
deux cd de ces problématiques
mais nous on souhaite vraiment que le
sport soit exemplaire sur ce plan là sur
tous les plans mais aussi sur ce plan là
parce que parce qu'on a un devoir à
l'égard de ceux qui nous regardent ceux
qui pratiquent ce reporter oui sur sur
l'implication des fédérations dans cette
lutte on a des dépositions en fait c'est
assez diverses et variées est ce que
vous ne craignez pas que si on retire
aux fédérations le pouvoir de sanction
existe le risque de les voir se
démobiliser en quelque sorte d'embellie
mal je ne crois pas à face surtout si si
en même temps qu'on retire ce pouvoir de
sanction on réglemente les questions de
prévention c'est à dire que on ainsi
davantage les fédérations à faire de la
prévention
la prévention étant vraiment de notre
ressort je crois qu'il faut pas c'est
pas parce qu'on va retirer le pouvoir de
sanction qu'on va on va se désintéresser
de la lutte contre le dopage
bien au contraire et moi ce que je
recherche avant tout avec cette
proposition
c'est une équité tous sports confondus
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui nous
avons nous le sentiment de l'athlétisme
d'être finalement souvent montré du
doigt alors que il ya bien pire ailleurs
quoi alors je veux pas cibler tel ou tel
sport mais on le voit bien les
fréquences de match de rencontre voilà
donc mon avis là il ya du travail à
faire un vrai travail mais nous on a des
saisons qui son voile a ordonné un petit
peu l'hiver beaucoup l'été on n'est pas
sur la sellette tous les jours du coup
il n'y a pas de nécessité vraiment de
prendre des actes et des compléments
pour pour durer vous voyez il faut il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont crevés l'axé on peut pas être en
forme tous les jours ça il faut le
savoir
et voilà pour être en forme tous les
jours il faut s'accompagner de
d'un régime particulier l'être humain ne
peut pas être en forme tous les jours
c'est impossible de manière très très
ramassé très synthétique et vous pouvez
décrire en quelques mots votre politique
athlé santé que vous mettez en place
parce qu'avant ça vous caractérisent oui
alors effectivement nous avons été la
première fédération olympique il ya
maintenant presque 6 7 ans à nous lancer
dans une diversification de la pratique
de l'athlétisme au travers de l'athlé
santé loisirs donc avec une licence
spécifique
l'idée c'était d'utiliser l'athlétisme
est un sport de base
finalement on a notre sport c'est les
fondamentaux de tous les sports courir
sauter lancer et donc d'utiliser notre
sport et la préparation physique et
notre notre notre background en quelque
sorte pour faire de la prévention
donc pour des gens qui ne font pas
beaucoup de sport qui ont qui n'en ai
jamais fait et c'est pour accompagner
des malades
nous avons travaillé avec les
associations nationales fédérations
nationales de pneumologie cardiologie le
plan alzheimer avec l'association
française des des camps ce cancérologue
également et nous avons donc créé des
emplois de coacher ses santé qui sont
donc des professionnels qui donc encadre
l'activité qui ont une base de formation
brevet d'état athlétisme et un
complément de formation a porté par ses
fédérations santé et sont rémunérés pour
la chose sont recrutés par les clubs
sont des professionnels et donc à nîmes
dans leur club au sein de leur
territoire
c'est assez ces actions de la télésanté
nous nous avons donc pu développer des
relations avec un réseau de médecins sur
tout le territoire et aujourd'hui il est
fréquent de voir des médecins prescrire
des activités de tête les santé dans les
clubs et là où il ya un professionnel
parce que pour des malades si l'activité
n'est pas encadré ça peut être dangereux
je ne peux pas envoyer un malade dans un
gymnase yom en se laissant se
débrouiller les gestes qu'ils peuvent
faire peut-être contraire par rapport à
ces à sa pathologie et donc nous avons
des lois et ça marche très bien ça
marche très très bien très très bien à
tel point que d'ailleurs nous sommes la
seule fédération reconnue par me serre
la santé sur ce plan là
et puis on a été reconnue aussi par la
communauté européenne il ya deux ans on
a gagné on a gagné à l'appel d'offres
salle fédération européenne fédérations
sportives en europe à avoir
à voir donc été lauréat d'un appel
d'offres ce qui vous a permis d'ailleurs
de développer ce concept dans plusieurs
pays européens en allemagne en italie en
espagne et en hongrie
à la demande de la communauté européenne
donc la commission spécialisée
et pour nous c'est une façon aussi
d'exercer ce que l'état nous a donné
c'est à dire nous exerçons délégation de
service public nous est ce moi je
considère que la délégation de service
public c'est pas simplement de délivrer
des titres de champion de france
d'ailleurs je trouve ça un peu désuet
qui peut même anachronique par rapport à
aux fonctions régaliennes de l'état que
la délégation de service public c'est
sûr justement là la prévention santé par
là qu'une activité physique et sportive
et donc voilà nous l'exerçons de telle
manière de cette manière là et ça marche
plutôt très très bien et ça se développe
énormément ça se développe c'est tant
mieux
est ce que vous avez eu une idée je
pense que oui précise du nombre de
personnes concernées qui sont des
professionnels
alors nous avons assistance voilà nous
avons actuellement donc 160 coach athlé
santé 160 emplois nous sommes en train
d'en former une quarantaine dont en
forme 40 par an à peu près l envie
d'avancer
on a placé à salses sa sur la base d'une
volontarisme des clubs on n'a pas voulu
imposer aux clubs
évidemment donc on veut si on avait
imposé on aurait eu sans doute du mal à
démarrer l'opération mais par
l'exemplarité de ce qui se passe dans
tel ou tel club les clubs s'y mettent
progressivement et on a aussi des
contacts avec des collectivités
territoriales des départements des
régions la région île de france par
exemple
bientôt le département de seine-maritime
mots avec lesquels on passe des
conventions justement pour développer la
formation de leurs propres agents dans
ce domaine là on développe par exemple
la marche nordique est une activité qui
nous est déléguée par là par le
ministère si nous qui avons développé la
marche nordique en france et on forme
les animateurs de marche nordique
la marche nordique étant une activité
une des activités et plus accessible
pour quelqu'un qui est malade parce
qu'on marche avec des bâtons du coup
c'est moins traumatisant que de marcher
sans bâton ou de courir ce qui est
parfois
possible pour ses balades donc voilà
nous avons d une vingtaine de
conventions avec des collectivités en
france est de plus en plus on voit la
ville de strasbourg par exemple qui
référence aujourd'hui en france sur la
santé et la le sport santé a demandé on
va signer une convention au mois de
septembre avec la ville de strasbourg là
dessus pour les accompagner est ce que
vous pensez précisément que les
dotations par exemple des dotations de
l'état ne tiennent pas compte ne
tiennent pas suffisamment compte de ce
type d'implications nous avons été un
petit peu aidé au début par lui serre la
santé d'ailleurs sur la formation des
coaches de santé nous avons eu des
lunettes de 60000 euros il ya maintenant
six ans 5 6 ans et depuis effectivement
voilà c'est sur le propres moyens que
nous développons cela c'est donc voilà
une des priorités qu'on s'est donné sur
nos ressources
effectivement les dans les discours dans
dans l'est comment dire quand on négocie
la convention d'objectifs avec le
ministère des sports on nous indique que
c'est une priorité nationale mais il n'y
a quasiment pas de crédits pour donc
débrouillez vous on a quand on a été
lauréat de l'europe on a touché 240
mille euros ce qui nous a permis aussi
développer les actions sur tout le
territoire
voilà et puis pour le reste ce sont les
clubs les clubs qui vont chercher les
alors on a train on travaille avec la
des mutuelles actuellement les s'est
rapproché du mouvement mutualiste
on a signé une convention avec une
mutuelle qui s'appelle mcd et aux vies
et nous développons sur tout le
territoire d action prévention santé
pour leurs clients pour pour le grand
public voilà donc nous sommes allés
chercher les moyens ailleurs qu'au
niveau de l'état alors que c'est une
priorité nationale
et d'ailleurs je vais plus loin c'est
nous avons conscience et nous en avons
souvent discuté avec la mutualité
française c'est que cette action si elle
était développée à grande échelle par
beaucoup de fédérations
c'est une action qui permettrait de
lutter contre le déficit de la sécurité
sociale
parce que finalement prendre une licence
dans un club ça coûte beaucoup moins
cher qu'un traitement médicamenteux et
c'est moins nocif peut qu'aider des
contacts sont en cours avec la direction
de là
la sécurité sociale au plan national
pour aller vers une remboursement de la
licence pour des cas particuliers pour
des malades dans ce cas de figure là
donc c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
il ya une expérience qui est qui démarre
en alsace à strasbourg même sur ce plan
là merci stéphane mazars lui merci
monsieur présent il faut m'excuser pour
le motard la pratique de l'athlétisme il
ya la pratique du fond et du demi fond
où souvent les athlètes sont amenés à
faire des stages à l'étranger en
altitude ou autre est-ce que ça pose une
difficulté pour le suivi des athlètes
c'est ma première question et puis une
seconde question
l'athlétisme est un sport universel si
l'année est-ce que vous n'êtes pas le
sentiment parfois qui a eu une attitude
me tiendrais parler un peu de sport à
deux vitesses ou en tout cas avec
d'autres disciplines mais déjà à
l'intérieur de votre discipline est ce
qu'il n'ya pas de difficulté avec des
pays qui n'ont peut-être pas les moyens
aujourd'hui de mettre de mettre en place
une lutte antidopage aussi efficiente
fait en tout cas qu'ils seraient censés
être aussi fils y est que l'un d'entre
eux sur la première question sur les
stages les stages fédéraux encadrés par
la fédération
on en fait
en france et à l'étranger on en fait à
font romeu pour l'altitude où le disiez
on en fait approché strom c'est en
afrique du sud
aussi en altitude dans des conditions
remarquables d'accueil et de coûts c'est
moins cher dès l'approché strub que de
faire un stage en france faut le dire et
donc ceux qui sont encadrés par la
fédération il n'y a pas de souci on est
bien d'accord
évidemment il ya après alors de quand
même de moins en moins par rapport à
cette époque pour le signaler des
groupes autour d'un coach d'un voilà
deux coaches un peu gourou et ceux là on
les contrôle pas ils vont faire un stage
abul khair qu'aux états unis par exemple
on va pas cela on les contrôle pas et on
sait très bien la bulle caire que c'est
la frontière avec le mexique et que
voilà il ya déjà des questions là bas
bon alors on fait très attention quand
on la connaissance de sa voix la
surveillance derrière les contrôles
inopinés
voilà on cible un peu plus seat est là
mais on ne peut pas tout contrôler on ne
contrôle pas tous un exemple du
marathonien et typique
il est d'origine kenyane il vit
quasiment toute l'année au kenya on sait
pas ce qui se passe au kenya comme au
kenya il n'y a pas du tout de
réglementation comme chez nous on peut
pas avoir un interlocuteur local à qui
on pourrait demander d'intervenir de
faire un contrôle etc
c'est extrêmement compliqué voilà donc
ça c'est sur la première question après
sur le deuxième point c'était sur les
les pays
effectivement disons les pays européens
ils ont les pays économiquement plus
développés ont mis en place des
réglementations des outils etc comme la
france il ya encore beaucoup de pays qui
sont très en retrait tout ça et on le
voit aujourd'hui notamment en afrique où
même dans les pays de l'est ukraine
biélorussie russie ou peut-être que le
sport n'est pas organisé de la manière
que chez nous même bien qu'ils aient des
fédérations mais les fédérations
contrôle encore moins leurs athlètes
parce qu'il ya des enjeux d'argent les
enjeux de voilà de l'image etc qui
seront pris en main par des groupes pour
pas dire autre chose et est donc là
effectivement on à l'athlétisme est
universel vous l'avez dit c'est ce qui
fait à la fois le charme de notre sport
le dtn dit souvent que il a appris la
géographie en venant dans l'athlétisme
parce que effectivement n'importe quel
athlète de n'importe quel pays peut être
champion du monde y compris de pays dont
on n'a jamais entendu parler et
d'ailleurs en athlétisme c'est un des
rares sports où on inverse les logiques
économiques à la tête d'un pays pauvre
peut être champion olympique
ça n'existe pas dans beaucoup de sports
quasiment pas à kényans éthiopiens à
naples est des caraïbes d'un petit île
des caraïbes ou être champion l'habite
on en voit régulièrement
ça fait donc le charme mais aussi la
difficulté pour un athlète français de
monter sur un podium où un athlète
européen donc voilà au niveau des
résultats c'est extrêmement difficile
même si on a fait plutôt une très bonne
olympiades en termes de résultats là
depuis quatre ans mais mais en même
temps sur la réglementation dopage or là
on est vraiment dans l'inégalité la plus
totale et nous on le voit enfin iliad
est comment dire quand on observe des
athlètes sur un stade là aux jeux
olympiques je me suis amusé à les
observer
physiquement et quand vous voyez des
athlètes féminines avec de l'acné avec
des appareils dentaires d'autres pays et
je vais pas citer les pays mais vous
vous dites bon il ya un truc c'est pas
possible qu'à 25 ou 30 ans on est ce
genre de choses ça c'est des signes très
très clairs de prise de produits
illicites
mais en même temps comme ils sont
coachés par des pseudos obsessive
spécialiste de la programmation ils ne
se font pas prendre le jour j et ils
n'ont pas les contrôles inopinés que
nous on a pendant les stages en dehors
des en dehors des stages à la maison on
peut aller ça n'existe pas dans ces pays
c'est juste
juste faire un petit un petit complément
je suis pas si vous étiez là tout à
l'heure j'avais j'avais juste rappeler
que on travaillait avec le médical le
président on a vraiment mis un comité de
sélection
et quand on dit un athlète c'est déjà
moins mots forts il est sélectionnable
il n'est pas sélectionné donc ça veut
dire il doit être à jour sur son suivi
dans sa globalité
sinon il ne portera pas le maillot de
l'équipe de france ont déjà ça mais un
petit frein concernant les la complexité
du demi fond je vous rejoins
parfaitement donc ce qu'on a fait ce
qu'on a fait il ya quatre ans c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on a mis un manager
général j'aime bien le terme manager pas
agent manager général il doit coordonner
et regroupés dans une saison au minimum
de trois fois le tous les athlètes
quelle que soit la spécialité là on va
parler du demi fond donc c'est de moins
en moins isolé mais il y aura toujours
des cas de figure qui ont leurs
habitudes
mais c'est souvent les ceux qui sont
plutôt en fin de carrière
la nouvelle génération aujourd'hui il
semble pour certains apple shop seront
particulièrement
et tout ça pour vous dire que et les
forts potentiels olympiques ce que
j'appelle les x protos olympique on
essaie vraiment de les orienter
aujourd'hui le dernier cast et mahiedine
mekhissi de d'avoir un entraîneur un
cadre fédéral d'état voilà philippe
dupont qui est également manager donc
moi s'est rassemblée qui est que les
attaques ne se sentent pas isolés
je pense que ça aussi ça peut ça peut
aider l'athlète a pas faire n'importe
quoi voilà
oui le président tout à l'heure vous
donniez l'exemple de ses athlètes dont
on peut se rendre compte on peut pour
lesquels on peut avoir une forte
suspicion donc et le physique et puis
les résultats parfois aussi qu'ils
peuvent laisser songeur alors c'est
peut-être une question au directeur des
tn comment ça se passe à l'interné ce
que parfois quand il ya des tensions
avec les athlètes est-ce que vous avez
des remontées d'athlètes qui vous disent
mais moins directeur c'est plus possible
de continuer à m'entraîner comme je le
fais pour me retrouver le jour j en
confrontation avec des gens dont on sait
pertinemment que ne respectent pas les
règles
c'est vrai que dalle pour le grand
public que nous sommes finalement sont
massés peu témoin de ce type de tensions
qu'il pourrait y avoir et elles seraient
les victimes d'athlètes que font les
efforts au quotidien qui se retrouvent
après le jour dit alors le le message au
quotidien j'ai eu la chance d'avoir fait
du sport de haut niveau j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir participé à des jeux donc
j'ai un message qui que les athlètes
peuvent comprendre c'est que des
tricheurs y aura toujours les pays
étrangers façon c'est la vie comme ça on
sait très bien et il faut pas faute se
focaliser là dessus je crois qu'à un
moment c'est juste ce programme et avoir
une planification pour être au mieux de
sa forme le jour j c'est à dire des
événements majeurs que ce soit les
europe les mondes on doit pas être
spectateur et voir ce que font les
autres c'est pas un problème on le sait
très bien
maintenant ce qu'il faut se dire c'est
que on a une fédération internationale
on a et des actions en france qui sont
très forte là dessus et l'idf ce qu'a
rappelé bernard tout à l'heure vous
savez quand vous arrivez à des goûts et
bien avant berlin quand il ya plus de
deux mille prise de sang
et aujourd'hui ça commence à payer quand
vous voyez des kenya qui sont les mois
le terme se font taper les jamaïcains
qui sont pistés les russes je crois que
c'est une catastrophe et on a eu du
monde là au mois deux mois d'août à
moscou je crois qu et moi je crois en sa
sincèrement je crois et c'est le message
pour les il faut être positif pour voir
la bouteille à moitié pleine et un
moment je crois que ça portera ses
fruits pour cette génération trop à
göteborg
dernièrement aux championnats d'europe
en salle on a eu des jeunes athlètes
c'est vrai qu'ils sont jeunes et qu'on
peut être performant qu'on peut être
performant sur le demi-fond à savoir que
au niveau mondial c'est la france qui
est quand même assez performante sur le
demi-fond et nos actions c'est c'est du
dialogue c'est de relativiser
et puis de se dire que il y aura
toujours des tricheurs ça on le sait
parfaitement comme partout qu'on y aura
toujours des voix là il y aura toujours
des gens malhonnêtes mais il faut pas
focaliser là-dessus et il faut avancer
et je crois que aujourd'hui les athlètes
l'ont bien intégrés et ils savent
moi je les rassure en permanence en
disant que l'idf que la fédération que
la fld que que la france est vraiment
peut-être certainement précurseur et
c'est vrai que ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il faut une forme
d'équité
malheureusement c'est parce qu'on peut
retrouver dans d'autres pays ce qui
serait bien c'est que cette action soit
soit vraiment internationale tout
simplement voilà et je crois je remercie
mwali deux airs puisque bernard ont fait
partie et ses prises de sang bas jusque
tacle de garnier qui est que de quelques
chez look et de besançon et
effectivement il m'a dit il était en
charge de sa a des goûts et il m'a dit
il va y avoir quelques forfaits
donc effectivement comme par hasard et
eu des forfaits
donc voilà donc je pense que c'est la
crainte aujourd'hui on a eu des turcs
qui sont sortis on sait pas d'où bas
aujourd'hui malheureusement comme c'est
triste pour certains on a une athlète
linda marguet kaki sur 800 m qui fait 4e
au championnat d'europe aujourd'hui se
retrouvent deuxièmes
donc c'est triste c'est dommage mais
d'un côté il faut le prendre
positivement c'est à dire que on est
vraiment à la chasse aux tricheurs mais
ghani à partir du moment où on mène une
carrière de sportif de haut niveau
olympien des résultats jeux olympiques
ou ailleurs pendant cette carrière
on est sans doute confrontée autour de
soi en constatant tel ou tel fait entre
guillemets de dopage est ce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a quel que soit le sport
mais dans l'athlétisme comme ailleurs
des cas significatif au delà de ce que
le président rappelait tout à l'heure et
est ce que on peut s'expliquer pourquoi
certains athlètes viennent à se doper en
viennent à se doper
quelles sont les raisons selon vous qui
pousse à la tête à ce plan alors
personnellement
l'athlète peu la tête et quelqu'un
malgré son apparence solide combatif ça
reste un être humain ça c'est quelqu'un
de fragile
moi j'ai l'aspect humain est très
important moi je pense que qu'on est en
travaillant avec bernard giraud delà de
la technicité en athlétisme on avait un
problème humain problème des changes de
proximité mois tous les athlètes on
téléphone je veux dire quoi qui quoi
qu'il arrive les managers pareil de
spécialités puisqu'on a eu spécialité 9
maintenant puisqu'on en est bien sûr les
relais et aujourd'hui ce qui peut
pousser un athlète à faire c'est souvent
enfin on à rona ou deux cas de repentis
qu'on fait une erreur qui ont pris un
produit polluer ce que j'ai découvert
quand je suis allé au seuil on m'a
expliqué comment ça se passait qui
avaient des produits polluée quand il ya
eu la petite série je me rappelle à
l'époque handballeurs footballeur
judokas et ça ça il peut avoir à
l'accident par contre je pense que
l'athlète seixas comme quelqu'un de
fragile
c'est pas comme je dis la gloire a
plusieurs pères et la défaite est
orpheline et c'est quand la défaite est
orpheline qu'il faut être à leurs côtés
parce que c'est là qu'ils sont fragiles
c'est là que tout peut basculer voilà
après on peut pas tout maîtriser
c'est pas possible et donc en maîtrisant
pour vraiment réduire les risques
cette action qu'on mène c'est à dire
d'échangés au maximum d'être ensemble au
maximum qui ne soit pas isolée
ben ça réduit ça réduira certainement et
je souhaite de tout coeur mais je pense
que cela est du passé quatre années on a
pas on n'a pas eu trop de soucis par
rapport aux autres lap yade et avec
bernard et le service médical on est
vraiment on est on est on est très
pointu là dessus on est on est vigilant
là dessus on est vraiment dans la
prévention et on n'est à l'abri de rien
on être humain on sait pas on sait pas
comment il peut réagir
on sait pas son environnement des fois
voilà mais en tout cas on ne sait
vraiment de mettre de l'humain de la
proximité et de leur expliquer on a même
une personne qu'elle en permanence pour
la halle dans quinze jours on leur fait
on leur fait un petit exposé on va dire
avec monsieur michel marle sur sur le
problème de nos shows ce que je vous
avez cité tout à l'heure parce que ça me
cause beaucoup de problèmes
moi à mon époque je pense que ça aurait
été très dur pour moi mais en fait on
explique en effet le dessin se passe
très bien mais on va pas perdre notre
temps à chaque fois expliqué quoi a
justifié il peut y arriver des erreurs
mais je pense qu'à un moment il faut
aussi les athlètes ont tellement de
pression il ya d'autres sports
certainement un peu moi mais je peux
vous dire que moi mon objectif c'est de
réduire le maximum de pression pour les
athlètes ce qu'ils ont tracée à subir et
au delà tout ça donc par ses actions de
prévention
par ces actions des changes et qui
mesurent les risques qui peuvent prendre
les conséquences voilà donc c'est ça
aussi en tant que cadre d'état c'est ça
aussi mon travail c'est la prévention
voilà merci de compléter way sur cette
question pour certains athlètes
ce dock pcc soit le gain d'argent à
gagner d'argent
le marathonien dont je vous ai parlé il
est allé gagner 70 mille euros dgo voilà
avec soit 10000 euros pour un kényan du
de la campagne c'est plusieurs années de
voilà de bien-être voyez c'est ça peut
être que ça c'est aussi parfois des
petites organisations des petits groupes
avec un pseudo coach alors c'est pas le
coach officiel c'est pas l'entraîneur
officiel généralement l'entraîneur
officiel est au courant de rien du tout
il est un peu le dindon de la farce
mais c'est quelqu'un qui est à
l'extérieur qui pilote et qui conseille
sur le dopage donc des athlètes alors
des expatriés souvent d'origine
marocaine ou ou des pays du maghreb qui
vivent en france mais qui sont pilotés
par quelqu'un qui est là bas on a eu le
camp je dis ça on a eu des exemples et
qui les conseillent et qui au passage
évidemment se fait rémunérer la
performance en fonction des résultats et
donc vide et ça évite de ça ces gens là
on peut pas les attraper parce qu'ils
sont pas en france
et puis mettre en place des commissions
rogatoires internationales c'est
compliqué surtout pour des petites
affaires parce que finalement c'est pas
des grosses sommes
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit un jour donc
voilà donc voilà les raisons et puis il
ya effectivement l'athlète qui est en
perdition qui rêve je passe de monter
sur un podium qui arrive pas et qui
malgré le travail qui fait à
l'entraînement il n'y arrive pas non
plus et du coup un jour bah il passe à
l'acte bêtement j'ai dit bêtement entre
guillemets mais c'est souvent
accidentelle quoi voilà il se fait
choper donc voilà c'est les raisons pour
lesquelles souvent les athlètes bascule
dans dans le dopage
j'ai oublié de vous dire tout à l'heure
sur les sanctions
ça m'est revenue après aujourd'hui les
sanctions elles sont essentiellement de
suspension avec des durées différentes
moi j'aimerais que les sanctions soient
accompagnés de d'amande d'amende-
financière
je crois que cela serait encore plus
efficace que la suspension
c'est quand vous mettez deux ans un
athlète s'il a 25 ans il revient ya pas
de problème pendant les deux ans il
centrale il s'entraîne d'ailleurs
pendant les deux ans il va faire des
cures de p o
pour être encore mieux puisque là il a
disparu du champ personnes sans souci ça
arrive d'ailleurs en afs on a eu des
récidivistes comme ça mais si vous leur
mettez une amende financière
alors là c'est radical surtout que ce
sont souvent des gens qui n'ont pas de
gros revenus qui vivent de l'athlétisme
grosse amende ça le scotch pour toujours
voilà on en parle plus après d'ailleurs
on écran en portefeuille
prendre les gens en portefeuille dans ce
domaine là je pense que ce serait plus
efficace que de les suspendre dix ans
pour juste rajouter sur sur le cas de
cette personne
ce marathon qui a fait une belle
performance à savoir qu'avant les jeux
issus des partis il souhaitait partir au
kenya s'entraîner pendant quatre
semaines
donc pour moi il est hors de question le
staff donc les résultats ont été ce
qu'ils ont puisqu'ils ont été un haut
lieu on le voit très bien la ville km il
abandonné au bout de 10 km donc on est
vraiment dans la prévention
il ya une forme de dureté mais oui alors
le problème c'est que son entraîneur on
connait grand chose non mais c'est après
ton jeu c'est un tract dont ses
impressions pour moi et me wade il a
besoin de sa famille je suis pas là pour
la famille et je dis ma famille est
d'ailleurs mais par contre il est avec
l'équipe de france donc voila c c'est un
exemple j'espère qu'on en aura pas
d'autres mais sait des choses difficiles
à maîtriser aussi mais il faut garder
une forme de rigueur et voilà ce qui a
fait qu'ils abandonnent au but 10 km sur
les sportifs blessés
avez vous une sensibilisation
particulière aux problèmes et aux
risques du dopage leur égard est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est un moment là aussi
de fragilité psychologique où il faut
intervenir et avez vous une action la
matière alors effectivement la blessure
et et eu un moment de fragilité mais en
athlétisme plus que dans d'autres sports
l'athlète vie avec la blessure
prenant l'exemple de stéphane diagana il
a fait une longue carrière mais une
année sur deux il disparaît c'est parce
qu'il était blessé il avait pas de
performance mais il a vécu avec ce qu'il
a géré sa voix la barre stéphane
peut-être pas le meilleur exemple parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui avait un bon
niveau intellectuel et qui voit là
savaient comment dire gérait tout tout
tout ces problématiques
mais c'est vrai que ça peut être
l'instant tragi lité pour d'autres
athlètes on a eu l'exemple de naman
keita qui a été médaillé olympique à
athènes
qui donc était quelqu'un de très
construit tout mais qui a eu à m'en
donner un problème de fragilité liée à
une blessure et il a dit et à ce moment
là il était un peu perdu
même si laval alors là un banc
d'entraîneur médecins de sur quoi donc
très bon entraîneur un des meilleurs
français et il s'est perdu en allant sur
internet
en dix ans il faut que je trouve une
solution pour revenir il est allé
chercher des compléments alimentaires
aux états unis qu'il a commandés et il
n'a pas regardé les formules en tout cas
les a pas montré à son médecin elle et
ses formules étaient pollués avec des
produits dopants il s'est fait il s'est
fait comme ça à trappes les voilà donc
on assume et on a quand même moins deux
sur la blessure on a moins de cas de
blessés qui vont chercher les produits
parce qu'on vit et que la blessure
c'est quelque chose qui est partie
intégrante de la vie de l'athlète
notre reporter et stéphane mazars dans
cette lutte contre le dopage est ce que
vous partagez vos informations avec les
autres fédérations sportives avec le
cnes la police la gendarmerie les
douanes le bureau de prévention du
ministère des sports et c'est alors avec
le clash oui alors moins de rapport en
ce moment parce qu'on a moins de cas à
une certaine époque quand je disais
qu'en 2006 2007 on était vraiment là sur
le feu de l'actualité
on était souvent j'étais j'avais tant
que j'étais en contact avec le claé sont
partagés à la fois nos informations on
leur donnait des informations pour
effectivement
mener des enquêtes et donc ça aboutit
entre fédérations c'est un sujet tabou
on en parle car voilà et jamais de débat
au comité olympique entre fédérations
sur les sur le dopage
c'est un sujet thème voilà les gens je
pense le président pense que si on parle
de dopage c'est con on à du dopage mais
on veut pas l'avouer donc donc ça je
trouve ça bizarre mais bon c'est comme
ça
après avec avec le ministère des sports
très peu de contacts 20 quasiment pas de
contacts là dessus sur ce sujet là non
on a on a eu à chaque fois qu'on négocie
là on a un contact au moment de la
négociation de l'accord subjectif c'est
une fois par an on parle de tous les
problèmes y compris de ceux là et on a
on présente les actions que nous
proposons pour l'année et donc le bureau
spécialisé fall le département médical
spécialisé nous accompagnent modestement
mais nous accompagne financièrement
petites subventions à ces voix là mais
il n'y a pas entre deux il n'y a pas de
discussion particulière entre deux oui
vous parlez de la période 2006-2007 et
justement en 2007 président vous aviez
dénoncé je cite les petits réseaux
c'était la formule de trafiquants placés
auprès des sportifs et qui avait permis
le dopage de plusieurs athlètes
oui donc aujourd'hui quelques années
plus tard ce que vous avez sentiment que
ces petits réseaux continuer à exister
on risquera dit qe 1 et continue c'est
surtout qu'ils sont basés hors france en
espagne et au maroc
donc il existe toujours les athlètes
concernées ont été tous suspendus et
avec des sanctions parfois très lourdes
certains sont parvenus on les a plus ils
ont disparu
certes certaines sont revenus mais
évidemment pas avec le niveau de
performance qu'elle avait à l'époque il
ya toujours ces réseaux il ya toujours
autour de certains athlètes
certes ces réseaux sont souvent composés
d'anciens athlètes de haut niveau de ces
pays qui ont d'ailleurs de parfois des
palmarès éloquent et qui vivent ou qui
survivent avec ce genre de choses
et b mais bon on progresse quand même
puisque tous les athlètes français en
tout cas concernés ont été sanctionnés
ont été coincés ou certains ont senti le
vent du boulet et puis on arrêtait de de
même mais mais pour d'autres athlètes en
belgique ou ailleurs ça continue ou en
italie ou en espagne ça continue en
france on l'a réussi à éradiquer le
problème pour l'instant ses fans bazar
promis d'être
oui bref oui c'était juste pour faire
préciser votre propos quand vous avez
parlé du fait que peut-être au-delà de
la suspension celle de la section
sportive
il faudrait peut-être donc également
qu'il y ait alors pour le coup un volet
pénal c'est ça oui évidemment des
financières donc vous seriez pour la
pénalisation de alors de l'usagé de
produit dopant la demande financière
c'est une pénalisation
bah oui mais pas au delà je veux dire
c'est dans la hiérarchie des fautes
c'est pas eu de faute dramatique on va
dire à la fête a tué personne il s'est
abîmé lui-même en quelque sorte mais la
manne financière allait au portefeuille
je pense que ça peut être radical enfin
dans le transport après dans d'autres
sports c'est peut-être insignifiant
compte tenu des enjeux financiers
mais chez nous ça peut être radical
bah non je suis désolé je ne savais pas
si non cela vous j'aurais demandé dames
et messieurs nous arrivons au terme de
cette rencontre
avez vous quelques mots de conclusion
nous avons bien noté que vous aviez été
c'est parfois le cas c'est le président
dans votre présentation d'entre dans vos
propos liminaire vous avez évoqué
plusieurs pistes et plusieurs solutions
que vous attendez nous en avons pris
bonne note
nous vous laissons le soin de conclure
si vous le souhaitez par quelques mots
la juste une question c'est la procédure
que vous engagez va déboucher sur un
toilettage de la loi de la
réglementation actuelle je vais laisser
le rapporteur quelque peu au fait que
moi puisqu'il est à l'origine de cette
commission
connaître les tenants et les
aboutissants c'est en tout cas notre
notre ambition oui l'objectif recherché
c'est notamment de contribuer à la
future loi cadre sur la modernisation du
sport qui doit passer en conseil des
ministres avant la fin de l'année 2013
donc effectivement notre souhait c'est
c'est d'apporter un certain nombre de
propositions
nous sommes très attentifs effectivement
préconisations qui sont exprimées par
les uns et les autres et sur ce plan là
vraiment l'ultime question monsieur le
président vous êtes président de la
fédération depuis 2001 est ce que vous
avez senti depuis 2000 à la pression
s'accroître les risques s'accroître
vis-à-vis des athlètes en matière de
dopage en france ou en grèce en france
non ce sera aux tourangeaux de président
en france on a pris vraiment le problème
à bras le corps c'est à dire que t'es
con à une suspicion on a ce qu'on
appelle les listes cible est là donc on
a des contrôles inopinés plus fréquents
on travaille en coordination très très
pointue avec les f là dessus si nous on
peut pas contrôler ces livres qui va
chercher l'individu là où on sait qu'il
est donc dont on n'a pas plus de
pression les réseaux sont les mêmes
iraizoz dont je parlais sont exactement
les mêmes les comportements sont les
mêmes depuis 15 ans et mais comme on est
extrêmement vigilant on a beaucoup moins
de problèmes beaucoup moins qu'on en a
eu dans le passé merci
merci pour ces propositions de bercy
pour l'ensemble de ce que vous nous avez
dit stop voilà pour les travaux de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur le
dopage si vous souhaitez revoir
l'intégralité des auditions elles sont
disponibles en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne
journée à tous